[MUSIC]
I am now introducing the median string
problem, and
to define this problem, we need to define
the notion
of distance not only between k-mers of the
same size,
but also the distance between a k-mer and the
longer string.
So what is this distance between two
strings of different lengths.
We simply start from a smaller string (a k-mer) and
compare it to the first k-mer
in the text.
Distance in this case is seven, we move
further. distance
six, continue, continue, continue until
the end of the string.
And then, return to the place where the
distance was minimal.
So in this way, we will find a k-mer within
a longer string that is most close
to our k-mer of interest, and this is the
distance between a pattern and a string.
What is the distance between a k-mer and a
set of strings.
In this case, it's simply the sum of
distances
between a pattern and each string in the
set.
For example, for a pattern AAA
and a set of strings shown on the slide,
we can compute distance with every string
and simply sum up all the distances.
The result
is five.
And median string for the set of strings
Dna is a k-mer pattern minimizing distance
between pattern
and DNA over all possible k-mers.
And our median string problem will be
based on the
problem we formulated before, which is yet
another equivalent motif finding problem.
If you remember this problem, then it
looks like
even more complicated than the original
motif finding problem,
because in this problem, we need to find
a k-mer and a set of motifs satisfying
certain properties.
But in fact, the only thing we need to
find
is a k-mer pattern as shown in this median
string problem.
In this case, we search for a k-mer
pattern minimizing distance between this
pattern and the
set of strings Dna (among all possible k-mers).
Now, there is a very simple algorithm for
solving this problem.
We simply need to try all possible k-mers
and see whether the
distance between the pattern and DNA is minimal
among all possible k-mer.
The running time of this algorithm is 4 to
the power k times n*t*k, where
we analyze
t sequences of length n.
So what we have just accomplished?
We started from motif finding problem, and
the brute
force algorithm for solving this problem
was incredibly slow.
We've turned it into yet another equivalent
motif finding problem,
and through this problem, we were able to
switch to the median string problem
with this very different run time.
In fact, it's still an exponential
algorithm
but for practical applications (where k
is usually less than 15)
we still can run this algorithm. So
dramatic improvement on the Motif Finding
Problem that we started from.
So sometimes, change of perspective helps.
And to move further,
we will notice that although the Median String
Problem is much faster than the Motif Finding
Problem,
it's still slow if we search for
long motifs
and little bit later we will figure
out how to deal with such motifs.
Our last topic in this segment is Greedy
Motif Search.
We'll now talk about a greedy algorithm,
for solving the Motif Finding Problem.
Given a set of motifs,
we have already learned how to construct the
consensus string.
Now let's construct the count matrix
where in every column we simply
have counts for all nucleotides.
And also. this count matrix can be
transformed into the so-called
profile matrix where we have
frequencies of nucleotides in every column.
Now, these frequencies of nucleotides in
every column
can be viewed as a four-sided, biased
dice,
representing probabilities of ending up
on a given face of a dice.
And we can view it as
a probability distribution.
And if it is a die, let's ask a question:
"What is the probability that tossing
such a die based on the motifs will generate
a given string of DNA?"
For example,
what will be the probability for
generating a string shown at this light?
So given the following profile, we ask,
what is
the probability of generating the
consensus string, AAACCT?
And this probability will be simply
computed by
multiplication of corresponding elements
in the profile matrix.
If you take
another string, we will get a different
probability.
And you have already noticed that the
closer the string is to the consensus
string of the profile, the higher is the
probability of generating this string.
And now, we define the notion of Profile-most
probable k-mer in a sequence.
This is a k-mer with the
highest probability among all k-mers in
the string.
And here's an example of how I can
generate Profile-most probable k-mer in a
string.
We start from the first k-mer in the string,
compute probability,
and record it in the last column of the
matrix.
We continue until we fill all the matrix,
and
finally, select the largest probability,
which in this case, corresponds to the
red entry in the matrix.
And with this at hand,
we are now ready for GreedyMotifSearch,
which works in a very
simple way.
We start from the set of i-1 motifs
selected from the first i-1 sequences
and show how to extend this
set
of motifs by the motif in the i-th sequence.
What we do, we form profile of motif from
the first i-1 1 sequences
and then select profile most probable
k-mer in the sequence number i.
Afterwards, we iterate.
And that will the result in the greedy
algorithm for
solving the problem.
And we will see later whether it works or
doesn't work for our goals.